hey this is Preston Walker reminding you
to mind your decisions in 1982 the
mathematician Raymond Smolyan appeared
on The Tonight Show Starring Johnny
Carson he presented two different logic
puzzles the first puzzle goes as follows
John James and William are identical
triplets who look the same one day you
meet one of them on the street and you
want to figure out if the person is John
you know that John and James always lie
and that William always tells the truth
you can ask a single question whose
answer has to be yes or no also the
question can have at most three words
what question
could you ask while you think about that
problem here's another puzzle that he
asked there are a hundred politicians at
a party each politician is either honest
or crooked and they are not all of the
same type at least one is honest and at
least one is crooked if you pick any two
politicians at random at least one in
the pair is crooked
how many honest politicians are there if
you'd like to give these problems a try
pause the video right now and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
a solution
[Music]
so let's start out with the first puzzle
Johnny Carson first thought what about
this question what if I ask does John
lie Raymond explained this doesn't quite
work let's go through why we know that
John and James always lie and that
William always tells the truth
so if we ask does John lie John will say
no James will also say no and William
will say yes so we have one yes answer
but we can't figure out the difference
between John and James so does John lie
doesn't work Johnny Carson then thought
about this question what if I ask are
you John well John is gonna lie and say
no James is gonna lie and say yes
William is going to tell the truth and
say no so again we have a problem but
this is close to the answer in this
question only James answers yes can you
modify the question so that only John
says yes Johnny Carson then came up with
the answer are you James John is going
to lie and say yes James is going to lie
and say no and William is gonna tell the
truth and say no aha
we figured it out to identify who John
is you actually have to ask about James
and not John now let's go to the second
puzzle we know that there is at least
one honest politician that's part of the
given information we also know that in
any pair of politicians there's at least
one crooked politician could there be
two or more honest politicians no the
reason is if there were two or more
honest politicians then there would be a
pair of honest politicians you pick two
of them this is a contradiction that
every pair has at least one crooked
politician thus there can be at most one
honest politician and therefore there
must be exactly one honest politician
Johnny Carson actually figured this out
on this
while these puzzles might be a little
bit easier on the range of logic puzzles
I think is great that we have these
kinds of puzzles on late night
television so it just goes to show
puzzles can be an invitation to learn
deeper mathematics thanks for watching
and for making mind your decisions one
of the best channels on YouTube thanks
for watching and thanks for your support
[Music]